[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec à la Une la
fragile chaîne du froid les
professionnels des métiers de bouche
s'organisent à l'approche de Noël et
alors que le risque de coupure
d'électricité pèse sur leurs activités
reportage dans les Hauts-de-France à
suivre avec où TV la chaîne de la Voix
du Nord
sa vie et celle de son pays ont été
bouleversées il y a 10 mois au Léna
zelenska la première dame d'Ukraine m'a
accordé une interview exceptionnelle
lors de sa venue à Paris cette semaine
extrait de cet entretien à découvrir
dans ce journal en exclusivité leur
exhumation en avait tétonné plus d'un au
printemps dernier les sarcophages
trouvés sous le chantier de rénovation
de Notre-Dame de Paris s'expose à
Toulouse des résultats scientifiques
étonnants que nous dévoilera via
Occitanie sur place et puis enfin de
journal nous prendrons un bain de
jouvence au contact d'Elizabeth Devos
cette professionnelle du textile
continue à 81 ans de travailler pour sa
passion la production de vêtements et
des accessoires pour les enfants une
belle rencontre faite par la rédaction
de Canal 32
célèbre aurons-nous les fêtes sur
courant alternatif le sujet fait débat
en France vous le savez avec le risque
éventuel de coupure d'électricité cet
hiver alors si le gouvernement se montre
pour l'instant rassurant les
professionnels s'organisent face à cette
éventualité fromager charcutier traiteur
ou même poissonnier doivent assurer la
fraîcheur et la qualité de leur
marchandise une obligation légale qui
pourrait s'avérer difficile le temps
venu reportage sur un marché dans les
Hauts-de-France de Jérémy Aubron pour
Wéo TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord et
du Courrier Picard
danséal les produits frais attirent
toujours autant la clientèle mais avec
l'annonce de possible coupure de courant
certains consommateurs s'interrogent
d'un point de vue sanitaire
plus de deux heures
il va y avoir une rupture de la chaîne
du froid de toute façon faut pas tomber
dans la panique nos frigo n'auront pas
le temps de se réchauffer en fait s'il y
avait une coupure de courant de 10h ça
changera peut-être les choses mais je
pense pas que ça se dégrade aussi
rapidement viande poisson fromage sont
autant de produits dont la température
est soumise à une réglementation stricte
ce poissonnier se veut rassurant même en
cas de délestage sa chambre froide
pourra tenir le coup plusieurs heures
regardez ici on est dans une pièce qui
fait entre 0 et 2 degrés et chaque pièce
est glacée donc même avec une coupade de
courant il y aura pas de souci pas de
souci non plus côté caisse le commerçant
est bien équipé c'est une balance qui
sont branche en direct et s'il y a une
coupure de courant c'est sur batterie
c'est la batterie
mais dans cette boucherie à quelques pas
de là pas de glace pour maintenir une
température constante ces viandes ne
doivent pas dépasser 4 degrés à coeur la
vitrine est ouverte alors en cas de
coupure pas question d'attendre deux
heures avant la coupure d'électricité
nous serons obligés de prendre notre
marchandise de le remettre dans les
chambres froides pour s'assurer que le
produit reste frais on serait obligé de
fermer la boutique oui on préfère que ça
arrive en janvier qu'en décembre ce sera
certainement plus calme ça va être à
partir de 18h donc
on est obligé de faire avec et on fera
avec dans un contexte économique tendu
les commerçants sont résilients et
assurent que la qualité des produits
frais sera toujours au rendez-vous
à savoir si la clientèle osera pousser
les portes d'un commerce plonger dans le
noir
voilà et en plus des préoccupations
énergétiques c'est le budget des
consommateurs qui est impactés en cette
période des fêtes chasse aux promotions
anticipations ou recours en seconde main
les Français ne manquent pas
d'imagination pour continuer à se faire
plaisir malgré l'inflation écoutez à ce
propos c'est quelques réactions
recueillies à la Martinique à l'heure du
rush des courses de Noël par José le
Chertier pourvient à TV sur place Noël
effectivement je prépare pas du moins à
l'avance donc six mois à l'avance je
mets un petit peu à chaque fois ce qui
fait que ça permet d'avoir une belle
enveloppe
donc non j'ai pas vraiment établi de
budget mais j'ai déjà un petit peu les
prix des jouets que je veux en tête ces
reconditionné et c'est écologique aussi
je trouve que c'est écologique c'est
bien de refaire vivre des appareils une
fois qu'ils ont déjà été utilisés
avec l'inflation et la crise actuelle on
a un peu plus de monde qui viennent
effectivement vendre des produits et on
a une nouvelle clientèle qui est tenté
par la consommation de produits
d'occasion
et puis en métropole aussi les
consommateurs sont attentifs pour éviter
les dépenses tropées levées ils peuvent
compter à ce propos sur l'action
d'associations comme le Secours
populaire à Limoges comme vous le voyez
sur ces images la structure a ouvert une
boutique éphémère où sont proposées en
ce mois de décembre produit Vintage joué
ou encore objet de décoration des images
de nos partenaires sur place de 7 à
Limoges voilà Noël qui rime aussi
historiquement avec Solidarité la preuve
dans la Sarthe ou une association
organisait la troisième édition du Noël
des sans-abris séances de coiffure
opticien distribution de vêtements mais
aussi repas de fête les sourires étaient
bel et bien présents sur les visages
comme a pu le constater Anthony Python
pour LM TV Sarthe
les visages se décrisent pour laisser
place au sourire des personnes à la rue
ont pu poser leur bagages et profiter un
peu de la magie de Noël
là la chaleur humaine et l'ambiance
tout tout ce contexte et ça fait du bien
j'aime bien la convivialité j'aime bien
le rencontrer d'autres personnes en
galère comme moi et ouais franchement ça
vaut le détour ça valait le coup de
venir quand sort là on pense pas nos
petits soucis quotidiens
la soirée entière est placée sous le
signe de la solidarité le stade Marie
Marvin est mis à disposition des
associations et des personnes en
situation précaire ici la cravate
solidaire offre des vêtements chauds et
des duvets aux personnes sans abri j'ai
trouvé un manteau
on sait pas quelle température on va
avoir quand ça commence à être froid
comme ça maintenant à mon avis
on va on va le sentir passer à côté ce
sont les apprentis du CFA coiffure du
Mans qui s'occupe des plus démunis
beaucoup n'avaient plus été chez le
coiffeur depuis des mois voire des
années c'est une économie quand même
mine de rien quand on voit qu'une une
coupe de cheveux chez le coiffeur c'est
tout de suite quand même 25 euros on
voit dans leurs yeux que enfin ils sont
heureux d'être là ils sont heureux de se
faire bichonner donc ça me fait plaisir
en fait de voir des gens avec un sourire
et des prestations auxquelles ils n'ont
pas accès vraiment déjà parce que eux je
pense que ne prennent pas le pli d'y
aller et parce que il y a tout un tas de
préjugés à dépasser et là c'est une
soirée où il y a zéro préjugés il y a
que de la bienveillance une soirée un
peu hors norme donc qui a mis du baume
au cœur aux personnes de la rue Noël
c'est surtout ça la solidarité
le reste de l'actualité marquée par la
mobilisation en faveur de l'Ukraine
Paris accueillez cette semaine deux
conférences internationales pour
soutenir le pays endommagé par près de
10 mois de conflits des rendez-vous
auxquels assisté bien sûr Dennis
schmihal le Premier ministre crainien
qui était l'invité de l'émission Face au
territoire ce jeudi sur TV5 Monde
regardez cet extrait où le chef du
gouvernement ukrainien évoque les
efforts développés par la France pour
soutenir son pays monsieur le Premier
ministre c'est très important l'argent
c'est le nerf de la guerre le président
d'elinsky me disait que l'art de la
communication l'été aussi mais est-ce
que l'argent est devenu véritablement ce
qui pourrait permettre à l'Ukraine de
vaincre
le soutien tout d'abord moral de nos
partenaires le soutien du peuple
français ne semble reconnaissants au
président Emmanuel Macron et à son
épouse qui se tiennent sincèrement
l'Ukraine et ça c'est très important
premièrement l'argent
sont très importants aussi bien
évidemment pour reconstruire les
infrastructures et pour de permettre de
donner aux gens des services de l'infras
des infrastructures de base pour ne pas
arriver à une catastrophe humanitaire
bien sûr nous sommes reconnaissants et
nous sommes
impressionnés par l'aide du peuple
français de l'État français hier il y
avait des milliers de personnes qui ont
soutenu la première dame Selena nous
avons constaté l'intérêt des sociétés
françaises lors de la conférence initié
par le président Macron nous voyons le
rôle de leader
de la France dans le renouvellement
reconstruction de l'Ukraine et dans le
soutien de l'Ukraine dans cette guerre
face au territoire avec le Premier
ministre ukrainien Dennis schmihal est à
voir où à revoir sur le site internet de
TV5 Monde et de ses partenaires
Ouest-France Nice-Matin français et 20
minutes
l'appui au peuple ukrainien qui faisait
également l'objet mardi dernier d'une
soirée caritative organisée par la
fondation de la première dame
ukrainienne au les nazaelenska pour
l'occasion des célébrités avaient fait
le déplacement comme vous pouvez le voir
sur ces images de Christophe frigo
Brigitte Macron était notamment présente
dans la salle Pleyel à Paris une soirée
que j'ai eu la chance d'animer pour
récolter des fonds destinés à la
reconstruction d'établissements de santé
en Ukraine au Léna zelenska qui sera
enfin au cœur d'une émission spéciale
bientôt diffusée sur TV5 Monde la
première dame m'a accordée en
exclusivité un entretien lors de sa
venue à Paris elle y évoque notamment
l'évolution de son rôle et de sa vie
depuis le début du conflit regardez un
extrait
changer
d'un monde destin
personne ne pouvait prévoir qui aurait
telle que notre monde allait changer
autant
traverser autant d'épreuves
qu'on se trouve dans la situation où il
faut se battre alors tu changes j'espère
beaucoup que
[Musique]
mon activité en tant que première dame
en temps de guerre dans mon pays est
efficace
et je sais de le rendre encore plus
efficace je ne m'attendais jamais
que la vie
face à moi je suis persuadée que plus
l'objectif est
durer
donc c'est une question de durée
d'endurance je sais que je peux encore
courir et j'espère beaucoup que nous
allons aller jusqu'au bout
l'émission et l'interview avait colléna
zellenska sera donc à découvrir en
janvier sur l'antenne de TV5 Monde
l'acteur Alain Delon y participera
également en interprétant des poèmes de
ta race jeffensko le grand poète
ukrainien sans transition dans ce
journal penchons-nous à présent sur ces
résultats dont je vous parlais dans les
titres des voyelles il y a quelques
jours autour des deux sarcophages
retrouvés sur le chantier de Notre-Dame
de Paris l'équipe scientifique chargée
d'analyser les cercueils n'a pu lever le
voile que sur une partie du mystère
c'est l'une des identités désormais
connues la seconde ne l'est toujours pas
explication et sujet de Lisa Hervé pour
bien Occitanie
[Musique]
là s'appelle Antoine de la porte l'autre
est encore inconnue c'est ce que révèle
les premiers résultats de l'étude des
deux sarcophages découvert lors de
fouilles préventives à Notre-Dame et que
j'y mets en début d'année c'est cercueil
de plomb a été acheminé à Toulouse pour
être analysé un moment qu'attendait tous
les scientifiques plein d'envie de voir
ce qu'il y a enfin dans ces dans ces
cercueils qu'on a fouillé sorti de
Notre-Dame puis déplacer qu'on a auquel
on a pensé tout le protocole on a pensé
pendant des mois et donc on y était
enfin donc oui on avait juste envie
c'était que la découpe soit terminée
qu'on puisse enfin sauver le couvercle
et donc ça là ce moment là c'était
vraiment plein d'émotions c'est
fouillant été supervisés par l'INRAP en
collaboration avec la fac de sciences le
CNRS et le CHU de Toulouse et c'est dans
le laboratoire de l'hôpital que les
analyses ont été réalisés la découverte
ici est vraiment exceptionnelle dans le
sens où on peut étudier avec les
techniques modernes et le matériel
d'imagerie médicale notamment on a pu
ouvrir très proprement ces cercueils
sans avoir à les détruire donc on peut
vraiment les étudier d'une manière fine
chacun de ces cercueils pèse plus de 200
kg si l'un des défunts a une déformation
crânienne et été sportive sans identité
reste encore à découvrir l'autre a
rapidement été identifié grâce à une
épitaveggravée sur son cercueil il
s'agit du chanoine Antoine Delaporte
pour une partie d'émotion de découvrir
ce chat noir etc qui d'habitude
finalement n'existe pas toujours en
archéologie parce qu'on a souvent des
des numéros face à nous surtout pour ces
époques où on est dans des endroits
moins prestigieux et des cimetières qui
avec des gens que qui sont inhumés
côte-à-côte si l'analyse globale devait
être rendue dans deux ans les premiers
résultats sont attendus au premier
semestre 203
c'est une première en France près de
Grenoble la ville de Fontaine va
accueillir une forêt urbaine sur une
zone industrielle 500 mètres carrés
dédiés à la renaturation d'un espace
urbain piloté par l'Office National des
Forêts ce projet vous envoyer quelques
images à l'écran vise à planter jusqu'à
170 arbustes et 85 arbres pour créer une
véritable mini forêt en ville les
détails au micro de Mirco petchi
journaliste pour Télé Grenoble regardez
l'objectif de ce projet c'est de ramener
un petit bout de la forêt qu'on a juste
derrière nous parce que Fontaine a la
chance d'avoir le bois des bouillant sur
son territoire on n'est pas sur un
projet où on met un arbre tous les 10
mètres le long d'une rue on est vraiment
sur quelque chose de dense et c'est ce
qu'on voulait aussi on est sur 500 m²
pour environ 500 plans qui vont être
plantés des arbres et des arbustes
recréer un milieu qui puisse être le
plus faroder possible à la aux insectes
au micro mammifères un jour aux oiseaux
l'objectif c'est qu'elle s'auto gère le
plus possible presque de grands espaces
extérieurs aux tout petits intérieurs
dans ce journal direction la Bretagne ou
une boutique de 4 mètres carrés
seulement vient d'ouvrir chez pomponette
c'est son nom et c'est une friperie
minimaliste où il est tout de même
possible de chiner à travers 250
références au portage un peu serré
forcément de Guillaume satigo et de
Dimitri glomski pour TVA à Rennes on va
au bout de la boutique de mes parents
donc on traverse l'épicerie et là on
arrive chez pomponette 250 pièces de
textile et de merceries pour 4 mètres
carrés de surface des chiffres peu
communs pour une boutique de vêtements
c'est pourtant bien le cas à saintenoud
dans la friperie chez pomponette tenue
par Caroline ragono cette ancienne
auxiliaire de vie a décidé de changer de
trajectoire pour se tourner vers sa
passion de petite fille la mode en mai
elle a installé une cabine d'essayage et
175 cintres au fond de l'épicerie de ses
parents une reconversion qui comble
celle qui avait une idée précise du
concept de friperie qui soit abordable
et pas de la au prix du neuf je veux pas
que les gens repartent avec quelque
chose qui ne leur va pas qui ne leur
plaît pas qui qui ne leur correspondent
pas une philosophie locale et
éco-responsable qui rejoint celle de la
boutique familiale chez qui les amateurs
de vêtements peuvent venir
s'approvisionner par la même occasion
j'ai un petit rituel c'est je fais mes
courses ici et une fois par mois j'ai
mon jour chez pomponette je viens avec
mon argent de poche on va dire
les vêtements du mois est-ce que super
c'est qu'en plus en ce moment où on
parle d'inflation mais parce que
l'inflation est partout je peux venir
ici me faire vraiment plaisir avec des
pièces que je porte le concept
fonctionne Caroline dragonneau à
plusieurs projets pour la suite
notamment un défilé de mode à saint-cenu
de la collection printemps été 2023 pour
l'anniversaire de la friperie
voilà et après cette très utile et
étroite boutiques intéressons-nous à un
autre projet original celui du fast food
solidaire la préhème installé dans les
quartiers nord de Marseille ce
restaurant propose depuis quelques jours
ses premiers burgers associatifs une
ouverture sur fond de renaissance après
le départ il y a 3 ans de la mythique
enseigne américaine au m jaune sur place
le fonctionnement est innovant sans chef
c'est la bienveillance et l'expérience
d'anciens salariés qui donne le rythme
en cuisine images et réactions récoltées
par Charles louas pour le journal La
Marseillaise
de travail pour permettre aux gens de
s'en servir et d'avoir un tremplin et
une formation professionnelle et leur
redonner le goût de l'entreprendre et de
pouvoir s'en sortir nous n'avons pas de
bénéfice le bénéfice sont transformés en
excédent et sont reversés à vie comme
c'est une association qui nous permet de
continuer à faire de l'entraide et les
colis alimentaires une fois par semaine
allez restons à table dans ce journal
vous en mangerez sûrement cet hiver la
saison des endives vient de débuter dans
les Vosges une ferme locale produit et
vend en circuit court jusqu'à 30 tonnes
de ce légume par an une récolte impactée
cette année par l'inflation énergétique
et une météo très capricieuse des
tailles fermées croquants d'Aurélie
Colombelles et Dan Didier pour rejeter
les visions
la saison des endives a débuté la
récolte va s'étaler jusqu'au mois de
mars une production artisanale de 25 à
30 tonnes par an on les laisse un peu
plus de trois semaines donc dans la
salle de forçage donc là où on simule le
printemps pour qu'elles prennent
vraiment leur temps pour pousser pour se
développer et c'est ça en fait qui fera
que l'endive aura très très peu de coeur
vous pouvez tout manger sur l'endive et
surtout du coup peu d'amertume toute la
saveur de la salade provient de sa
racine qui contient les nutriments
nécessaires à la pousse des racines
d'abord mise en dormance en chambre
froide c'est une plante bise annuelle
donc elle va faire une chicorée
effectivement elle va avoir une racine
pivot donc qui va descendre comme un peu
comme une carotte et on va donc la semer
en fait en champ elle va faire sa
chicorer on va ensuite la couper à ras
pour récupérer que la racine et à partir
de cette racine dans un deuxième temps
on va produire nous l'endive ici ensuite
les racines sont mises dans de grands
bacs alimentés en eau plongée dans le
noir avec une température printanière
le bourgeon albinos se développe c'est
cependant une année difficile pour
l'endive consommatrice en énergie entre
les salles réfrigérées et la circulation
d'eaudi le légume a pris plus de 10% en
termes de coup de production au-delà de
l'aspect énergétique c'est une année de
sécheresse et ça c'est un impact sur les
racines c'est vrai qu'elles ont plus de
mal que certaines années à
gagner en grosseur c'est en circuit
court via les marchés de producteurs et
auprès des restaurateurs que la
production est vendue elle va intégrer
le menu d'hiver que ce chef cuisinier de
Vanier est en train d'élaborer on a
vraiment une chance d'avoir eu une
endive que je qualifierais de parfaite
avec très peu d'amertume et justement
c'est ce qui la rend très agréable et
très très coûteuse et pour cette fin
d'année c'est un roulé de fromage frais
et saumon qui permettra de présenter
l'endive lors des repas de fête
voilà lors de la retraite a sonné pour
l'Alouette 3 ce mythique hélicoptère de
la Marine véritable fleuron de son
époque il se retire après 60 ans de bons
éloignages au service le 31 décembre
prochain alors l'engin arrêtera
définitivement de prendre son envol
depuis sa dernière base du Finistère et
Stéphane Jezequel et Lionel loco pour
TBO ont rencontré ce qui vole encore au
quotidien avec la loi 3 de belles images
regardez
avec son design à la fois vintage et
très innovant l'alouette a rendu de
nombreux services à la marine au cours
des 330 000 heures de vol totalisés par
les appareils c'est un aéronef qui a qui
a fait toutes les missions de la Marine
qui a pratiquement embarqué sur tous les
bâtiments de la Marine et qui a touché
plusieurs générations de pilotes de
marins du ciel mais aussi de marins tout
court puisque effectivement elle a
énormément embarquée a permis à de
nombreux pilotes de l'aéronavale de se
former et de vivre des situations
extrêmes le lien est donc très fort avec
cet appareil il y a eu de la formation
en tant qu'instructeur il y a eu
également des opérations humanitaires
comme les opérations engagées après le
passage du cyclone Eline sur Madagascar
une journée j'ai eu l'occasion avec mon
équipage de d'extraire de la gang debout
laissé par le fleuve impopo 47 personnes
dont un moment donné une famille de six
personnes dont des bébés et une maman
avec ses
enfants c'était très touchant parce que
quand on est père de famille extraire du
danger des femmes et des enfants en bas
âge c'est quelque chose très très
touchant à 60 ans l'Alouette 3 est
encore en forme pour voler le secret de
cette longévité une rusticité mécanique
à toute épreuve pour l'assimiler à la
deux chevaux désert parce que tout est
simple tout est interchangeable sur
cette hélicoptère là ce qui fait que il
est relativement facile d'entretien et
on avait un stock de pièces détachées
suffisant pour le tenir jusqu'à
maintenant et là il faut tourner la page
quoi 60 ans je pense que c'est une belle
carrière ici honorable non non pour
vraiment passer maintenant à tourner
vers l'avenir et travailler sur les
nouveaux projets ce vendredi sur la base
de Lanvéoc ou vole les dernières
Alouettes l'état-major de la marine et
les anciens des flottilles dotés de cet
appareil rendront un dernier hommage aux
mythique hélicoptère qui partira
définitivement à la retraite le 31
décembre 2022 tout à fait autre chose
pour elle la retraite c'est hors de
question direction l'aube pour terminer
ce journal à la rencontre d'une femme
exceptionnelle Elisabeth Devos est une
matelassière aussi passionnante que
passionnée spécialisé dans la confection
de vêtements et accessoires pour enfants
cette octogénaire continue malgré son
âge sa production de textile le travail
c'est la santé diront certains une
rencontre enthousiasmante de la
rédaction de Canal 32 sur place regarde
la boutique atelier trois petits points
est à coller à la maison d'Elizabeth de
vosse après avoir exercé de multiples
métiers depuis 33 ans elle s'est
spécialisée dans la confection pour
enfants parce que j'adore les enfants et
j'ai tellement facile de travailler pour
les enfants vous savez c'est trop drôle
de travailler pour les enfants vous
voyez par exemple ça ah ben ça alors
madame je savais pas que les girafes
faisaient de la gymnastique Elizabeth a
commencé la confection pour des amis
avant d'accéder au statut d'artisan
métier d'art et conservation du
patrimoine vivant elle se définit comme
matelassière elle consacre près de 10
heures par jour à la découpe et
l'assemblage de tissus d'origine
française ou allemand
je préfère tout de suite
fait en fait les vagues autour
manuellement il y a des gens qui me
demandent de refaire des couvertures à
l'ancienne et Shrek le dessin moi-même
Elisabeth de vosse aime associer
solidité et praticité à l'instar de
cette veste réversible ou ses vanity
vendues en boutique salon ou sur
internet
alors que si vous mettez un fond en bois
que vous pouvez cliquer ça ne tombe pas
vous avez la boutique avec tout ce que
je fais après ça vous avez les promos et
après comment me contacter après vous
avez un bon de commande avec le port
suivant le poids donc je mets par
exemple couverture tel poids tel prix si
elle a toujours su s'adapter aux
habitudes de consommation à 81 ans elle
n'arrive ni à transmettre ni à s'arrêter
rien que l'idée de travailler autant
d'heures ils ont peur
ils ont peur alors moi je dis bah qui
était pas votre travail il fait ça
mi-temps essayez m'arrêter non la chose
qui est le plus important dans la vie
c'est de se lever et d'être content
d'aller travailler c'est pas de faire le
métier qu'on vous dira de faire ces
métiers que vous aurez envie de faire
c'est un choix de vie si vous levez le
matin en étant content de travailler ça
vaut tout Elisabeth s'amuse à qualifier
sa motivation d'héréditeurs ses parents
et grands-parents ont travaillé jusqu'à
leur dernier souffle
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve très vite
pour une prochaine édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]